جدل واسع شهدته تونس اخيرا بسبب تصريح
وزير الشباب والرياضه حول اجباريه ممارسه
الرياضه في اماكن العمل لكن الباط ساخره
من القرار وراء انه لا يمكن تطبيق على ارض
الواقع فيما ايده اخرون باعتباره قرارا
صائبا يسهم في القضاء على الخمول الوزاره
وضعت بالفعل استراتيجيه لهذا الهدف من
خلال التنسيق مع وزارتي الداخليه والبيئه
لتوفير الظروف الملائمه والتطبيقا لقرار
الوزير انتظمت في الفعل اولى الحصص
الرياضيه في مقر رئاسه الحكومه تحت شعار
الرياضه في الاداره
[موسيقى]
هناك عند الطرق بحسب الخبراء تساعد على
انشاء البيئه عمل قويه اولها تقديم فرصه
تعلم اشياء جديده باستمرار او سقي
المهارات الموظفين الحاليه من خلال اضافه
مجموعه متنوعه من برامج التدريب الحفاظ
على التواصل مستمر مع الفريق ومشاركه
اهداف الشركه واسباب قيامهم بمهام العمل
المختلفه وسيؤدي ذلك الى ترسيخ معنى العمل
الجماعي لديهم تقدير العمل الجادراك كل
عضو في الفريق انه يمتلك مهاره مختلفه عن
العود الاخر هو امر بالبالغ الاهميه لذلك
احرص على اخبارهم ان الامر بدونهم سيختلف
وانا كل عضمهم في دوره وان مهمته لا تقل
اهميه عن مهمه يعد اخر التحفيز عبر تجربه
مختلفه لقاء الموظفين وتحفيزين كستقديم
مكافاه ماليه او زياده في المربى مرتبات
او ترقيات او مجرد تقديم خطابات شكر
انشاء مكان عمل جذاب فالدراسات تشير الى
ان الانتاجيه تزداد بشكل الملحوظ في مكان
العمل جذاب ويمكن الالوان مثل الازرق
والاخضر والاصفر تحسين التركيز وزياده
الابداع بالاضافه الى السماح لموظفين
بتخسيس مساحه عملهم وجعلها خاصه بهم على
العموم سال الناس في مصر ما هو الامر الذي
يمكن ان يتوفر في العمل لتصبح حياتك افضل
[موسيقى]
والله انا عاوز يبقى في مرتب كويس يبقى
فيه مواصلات يبقى الدنيا دي تبقى كويسه
اللي هي تساعد على ان احنا نبني في
المرتبات مثلا ان انت بتشتغل في حاجه برده
ما بتاخذش المرتب اللي بيجزيك
مرتب كويس يقدرني حياه كريمه ده بس انا
محتاجه من صاحب العمل اه من العمل اللي
انا فيه عموما علشان يتمرن حياه مستقر
نفسيا ليا والاسره ان انت تكون مقتنع
بالعمل بتاديه تدي شغلك تدي وجبك بما يرضي
الله ربنا هيكرمك سيبك من ان انت مستني لا
استني ده ربنا هو اللي بيجازيك فيه
[موسيقى]
الواحد يقبض بالدولار عشان الواحد بقى
عايز يشتري تليفونات وعايز يشتري حاجات
محتاج مرتب كويس عشان نقدر نعيش في الحياه
عموما ما يحتاج تدريبات اكثر علشان نطور
من نفسنا في الشغل ونمشي خطوه او ناخذ ستب
حلوه لقدام بعد كده في حياتنا
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مدربه مهارات حياه رواد الخير
وانت يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا فلسطين
اليوم عن المتطلبات بالفعل حتى يكون
الموظف براحه اكبر في مكان عمله يعطيكم
العافيه اول شيء هلا اهم شيء نعرف انه كل
ما زادت بيئه العمل ايجابيه بتزيد
الانتاجيه وهذه دراسه عملتها جامعه
بيئه ايجابيه نفسيا وماديا احنا بنطلع
عليهم الثنتين مع بعض نفسيا بانه انا اام
الموظف زي ما حكينا الرياضه قد من الرياضه
ممكن تقلل سترس تقلل همم القلق اللي موجود
عنده بعدين بتعرف احنا بنقضي وقت بالشغل
اكثر بيوتنا احيانا كسر الروتين عن طريق
الرياضه وعن طريق فعاليات جوه بيقتل عمل
كثير بيساعد على انتاجيه اكثر بالنهايه
نتفق على شيء ما في شيء اسمه شركه تنجح من
غير موظفين الاساس نجاح اي شركه الموظفين
ما في موظفين عندهم انتاجيه عاليه وعندهم
قابليه ليشتغلوا بطريقه احسن ما نحكم في
نجاح بالشركه هي لا تعتمد على مدير او
صاحب عمل هي بتعتمد على الاساس اللي هم
الموظفين شو اللي بخلي اصلا انه الشركه
يعني تفتقد للسعاده المؤسسيه اه هلا في
كثير اسباب منها التفرقه بين المدير
والموظف انا مدير ما حدا بقدر يحكي معي
وجديد للاسف عن بلاحظ اشي احنا بنعرف كلنا
سياسه همم باب المدير المفتوح دائما للاسف
عم بيكون فقط بشكل ولما تعطي رايك عم
بيكون في صد بس بيقول لك انا دائما بابي
مفتوح للموظفين ثاني شغله المنافسه اللي
غير ايجابيه بين الموظفين انا ما بدي اخذ
منك لا اتطور انا بدي اخذ منك ابين حاليكي
فهاي بتادي الى وجود سلبيات نفسيا يعني
موظفي فكره بدي اكون احسن منك لانه انا
بدي اثبت حالي
لا لانه مشان انا بدي الغي موظف فهاي كثير
عم بتصير برده فبتؤدي الى نفسيه مش مريحه
في الشغل طيب اضافه للرياضه لو بتحدث عن
احدث توجهات لبيئه عمل افضل احسن توجهات
انا من ناحيتي رياضه طبعا هذا شيء اكيد
كثير فكره حلوه اثنين ما نطلع بس على
ساعات العمل الموضوع مش قدر قد ما هو
نوعيه اعطي في الاكسبيرتي لا الموظفين
مشان ينتجوا اكثر والتعامل دائما يكون
قريب من موظفينك مش بفوقيه يتعاملوا
بالنهايه مديره كان موظف انت كنت موظف في
يوم من الايام فلما تصير مدير تكون عارف
شو مشاكل لهم اللي تقدر تتعامل معاهم طب
هل برايك روند في هاي الحاله يجب على
المؤسسات انه يكون في مكتب لمعالج نفسي كل
موظف يشعر بالغضب يروح يلجا لو ممكن يحل
لنا مشاكلنا مثلا هلا مش معالج نصيره نحكي
همم ممكن يكون في غرفه
تفضفض فيها محالك يعني مرات ممكن كثير
تكوني انت وا سترس اا تروحي تقعدي بهاي
الغرفه للتروقي لا تقعدي همم لا ممكن
امراه تتكسري اشياء جوه الغرفه يكون في
عندهم هذا الاوبشن عشان تفرغي طاقات بس
معالج نفسي بتخيل انه ان شاء الله ما حدا
من الموظفين بوصل المدارس انه بده معالج
نفسي ليروح على الشغل وهم بيكون في كثير
علامه استفهام على الشغل وفيه يعني اذا
وصلت لها معالج نفسي اترك دوامي احسن ههه
طيب تحسين جوده العمل
الناس
عملوا كتاب كامل للمرض العقلي ممكن يؤثر
عليك وين نفسي اذا كنت بيبي اتعمل غير
ايجابيه همم
اذا حبيت الشغل
يلا ثمان ساعات
حسب اللي حواليكي شفتي هاي البسمه مثلا
بتجيبك على الشغل فهذه البسمه
هاي الطاقه بتخليك تيجي على الشغل بنفسيه
ممتازه شكرا جزيلا لك مدربه مهارات حياه
رواند الخضر